Professor Robert
Shiller: I'm Bob Shiller.
I have the pleasure of
introducing this Okun lecturer,
Lawrence Summers.
I wanted to say first that the
Okun Lecture Series was funded
by an anonymous donor in honor
of Arthur Okun,
who was Professor of Economics
here at Yale,
who later became Chairman of
the Council of Economic
Advisors,
who founded with William
Brainard the Brookings Papers
on Economic Activity and was
widely admired both here at Yale
and around the world as an
economist that had a lot of
impact on policy--an economist
with a purpose.
It's altogether fitting that we
have Lawrence Summers here as
our Okun lecturer for this year.
Larry Summers--I'll go through
his career briefly--he started
out at age sixteen at MIT as a
physics major.
Fortunately for us,
he switched into economics at a
very--as a teenager.
He got his PhD at Harvard.
He got tenure at Harvard at one
of the--he's one of the
earliest, at age twenty-eight.
In 1993, he won the John Bates
Clark Medal for the best
economist under the age of
forty.
He joined the staff of the
Council of Economic Advisors.
He was Undersecretary of
Treasury for International
Affairs.
He was Chief Economist at The
World Bank.
He was the U.S.
Secretary of Treasury.
He was President of Harvard
University and now he is a
University Professor at Harvard
and also a Director at D.E.
Shaw.
His research has done truly
stunning--I've always been a
huge admirer of it--and it
covers many fields--public
finance,
labor, macroeconomics,
and finance,
in particular.
I thought I would just conclude
my introduction with a couple of
famous Larry Summers quotes.
These quotes are advice to
graduate students but they might
as well be advice to any
researcher.
Larry is quoted as saying,
"You might as well work on big
problems because it takes just
as much time to write a paper on
a little problem as on a big
problem."
Another bit of advice to
students: "Do your research on
the economy not on the economic
literature."
I think that's a bit of wise
advice.
But, I think that--to me,
that says something about the
essence of his research style.
He's been extremely potent in
his work on very important
results that kind of shape our
view of the world and I think
that it's this research style
that is part of the reason why
he's been tapped for such
important positions.
I'm pleased to introduce Larry
Summers.
Professor Larry Summers:
Thank you, Bob,
very much for that overly
generous introduction.
At least one thing you said
wasn't quite right.
It may or may not have been
economics' good luck when I left
physics, but it was surely the
good luck of the physics
profession when I left physics.
I appreciated your generosity
in reflecting on the different
sectors in which I've had a
chance to work.
When I first moved from the
University to Washington,
people asked me,
well what's different about
being a senior Treasury official
from being a professor at
Harvard?
I realized the answer to that
one was easy.
As a professor at Harvard,
the single worst thing you
could do was to sign your name
to something you had not written
yourself.
On the other hand,
in the Treasury Department,
it was a mark of effectiveness
to do so as frequently as
possible.
Then, I got back to Harvard and
had the honor of serving as its
president and people asked me,
what was different about the
University from Washington?
In those first months I gave an
answer that in retrospect seems
slightly breathtaking in its
naiveté.
I said, Washington is so
political;
there's so much opposition;
University is very different
from that;
we're all on the same side.
It is a real honor to be here
at Yale and it is a particular
honor to deliver the Arthur Okun
lecture.
I am told that I first met Art
Okun when I was one week old,
as he and my father were close
friends during the time when
they were assistant professors
at Yale together.
In fact, I grew up until a
certain age calling him Uncle
Art.
I don't have many vivid
memories, but I have a quite
vivid memory and I was able to
go back and place the year.
It was 1969 and Art delivered a
set of lectures,
probably a set of lectures like
this one,
at the University of
Pennsylvania and he stayed at
our house.
He stayed up telling my parents
a whole set of stories about
life as an economist with Lyndon
Johnson.
Some of the stories are a
little too raunchy to repeat
right here, but it was the first
inkling I had that this academic
research stuff,
like my parents did,
really could have a very direct
and real impact on the policy
arena.
I remember, especially,
somehow--I don't know what
determines what makes an
impression on you when you're
fifteen,
fourteen--but my father telling
me this story of how there was
a--and I have no idea whether
this story is actually true.
But, the story he told was that
there was a publication that the
Department of Commerce published
called BCD,
which stood for Business
Cycle Digest,
which compiled all the facts
about the business cycle and
whether the economy was up or
whether the economy was down.
Because of all this stuff that
economists had figured out,
like Art, we now had these
practical policies that we could
use so that when there was a
recession,
we'd stop the recession from
happening and when there was an
excessive boom,
we'd smooth off the boom.
So, we didn't necessarily have
to have business cycles anymore.
We liked calling the
publication BCD.
So, Art had had the clever idea
of renaming the publication to
The Business Conditions
Digest, to celebrate the
success of Keynesian economics.
Time went on and the first
great success,
if there ever were any great
successes of my career as a
graduate student,
came when Art Okun and George
Perry invited Kim Clark and I to
give what was the first
significant paper that I had
written as a graduate student,
on labor market dynamics and
unemployment,
at the Brookings Papers on
Economic Activity
Conference.
It was the thrill of our young
lives and it was also a vastly,
vastly better paper in the form
in which it was published than
it was in the form in which it
was originally written,
thanks to Art.
I have a final memory that
pertains to Art that also says
something about Art.
I remember sometime in the
early 1980s sitting at the lunch
table in the MIT faculty club in
a way that some of you who know
me won't find surprising.
I was declaiming on various
subjects with a certain lack of
reticence that perhaps was not
commensurate with my lack of
knowledge.
I asserted some proposition and
Paul Samuelson turned to me and
he said, Larry I just wrote a
eulogy for Art Okun,
who died recently,
and I said that in all the
years that I had known Art Okun,
Art Okun had never said a
stupid thing.
Well Larry, now I won't be able
to say that about you.
One of the things that gives me
particular pleasure in,
along with Greg Mankiw,
taking over the editorship of
the Brookings Papers on
Economic Activity from Bill
Brainard and George Perry,
who had done such a stellar job
for the last twenty-five years,
is the knowledge that it was a
project that had been initiated
by Art.
It was a project that had been
initiated by Art out of a
conviction that I have tried to
live by in my career and that I
hope in some small way to
illustrate with my remarks here
today--that serious economic
thinking can help one understand
the world much better;
that with the aid of the
metaphors and the models and the
measurements that come from
serious economic thinking,
one can direct economic
policies in better and in more
sensible ways.
As a consequence,
the lives of very large numbers
of people, most of whom who will
never hear of economics and
certainly will not study its
details,
will in some way be improved by
having higher incomes,
by facing less risk,
by being more secure as they go
through their livelihoods.
It's in that spirit that I want
to reflect today on some aspects
of macroeconomic thinking and
experience and then some aspects
of financial thinking and
experience and how they bear on
financial crisis.
Then tomorrow,
on the particular financial
crisis that we face right now,
what has been done,
what may happen,
what should be done,
and what can be done over the
longer term to make the return
of such a crisis more
important--less likely.
Art was preoccupied through
most of his career with the
central macroeconomic issue of
assuring stable growth.
To use language that's perhaps
more congenial to older than
younger ears--avoiding
underemployment and output gaps.
It's revealing that the journal
he founded was called the
Brookings Papers on Economic
Activity,
suggesting a concern with the
cyclical performance of the
economy.
He surely, as much as anyone,
would have subscribed to Jim
Tobin's famous dictum--that it
takes a heap of Harberger
triangles to fill an Okun
gap--or that the macroeconomic
issues of recession and
depression are terribly,
terribly important relative to
the microeconomic efficiencies
that are a preoccupation of a
very large number of economists.
This idea, this first idea that
Okun gaps exist,
and are large,
and are very important relative
to microeconomic inefficiencies
is one that is increasingly
unfashionable today.
Discussing them within the
context of what has been called,
although I suppose it can't be
called that anymore,
the new classical
macroeconomics is almost
impossible;
there's no role for any kind of
gap.
It's much like discussing
epicycles with a modern
astronomer.
Even within a Keynesian
tradition, the accepted versions
of the Keynesian model greatly
circumscribe the scope for what
was Art's major concern:
underemployment and the output
gap.
If one thinks about the
centerpiece of the supply side
of any macroeconomic model,
almost any macroeconomic model
post 1980, in some form or other
it has the implication that the
change in inflation is in some
way dependent on the output gap.
Perhaps it's the change in
inflation;
perhaps even more
problematically,
it's the unexpected component
of inflation.
Perhaps the causation runs the
other way and the output gap is
related to the--is caused by the
change in inflation or is caused
by the level of unexpected
inflation.
Any equation,
any theory of output that has
that property has a simple
consequence if you aggregate it
over a long period of time.
Namely, that if you look at the
difference between inflation at
the end of the period and
inflation at the beginning of
the period,
or equivalently,
if you look at the average
level of unexpected inflation,
which has to be zero,
it will relate to the size of
the output gap.
Therefore, if one thinks of a
steady state as being a state in
which unexpected inflation
averages zero or a state in
which the accelerant,
the change in inflation,
averages zero,
you know what the output gap
has got to be;
it has got to average zero.
This doesn't mean there's no
role for cyclical policy,
but it has the very strong
implication that what you gain
in the booms you lose in the
recessions.
If you have deeper recessions,
you will be able to have larger
booms;
that if you have larger booms,
you will be able to have--you
will be forced to have deeper
recessions.
In a sense, if one accepts this
idea, the subject of cyclical
fluctuations in macroeconomics
becomes an order of magnitude
less important than it was if
one maintained some older idea
in which it's possible to have
output gaps that are not offset
by subsequent gains in output.
To be sure, much has been made
of the point at certain moments;
there may be some impact of
non-linearity in the
relationship between the gap and
the change in inflation or
unexpected inflation.
If this relationship is
non-linear, then it's possible
that by running a smoother
economy, one can run a somewhat
higher-pressure economy.
In a world where
econometricians struggle to
estimate any kind of Phillips
Curve,
the idea that one can measure
with any precision a
non-linearity of this kind is,
at the very least, problematic.
Ironically, the Keynesian model
as it came to evolve--the
Keynesian model that--and the
Keynesian discussion that had as
its center piece the Phillips
Curve in some form,
in almost all of the forms in
which the Phillips Curve came,
was quite skeptical of the role
of macroeconomic policy in
affecting average levels of
output through time.
Very little room for Art Okun's
dedication to closing output
gaps or maintaining a higher
pressure economy as a way of
spurring economic growth or as a
way of promoting a more equal
income distribution.
Art's last–the last
decade of Art's professional
work was directed at questions
that in one way or another
relate to these equations.
His final book was entitled
Prices and Quantities.
His dominant professional
preoccupation was,
in his last years,
with how the rate of inflation
could be brought down with a
minimum level of the output gap
with,
as he would have put it,
a minimum sacrifice ratio.
It's not hard to understand why
these questions relating to
inflation and output were
preoccupations of Art's during
his professional lifetime.
It's interesting to think about
U.S.
business cycle history.
When people like me gave talks
about the economic outlook to
non-academic audiences fifteen
or twenty years ago,
it was considered a cleverness
to observe that American
economic expansions do not die
of old age;
they're murdered by the Federal
Reserve with inflation control
as the motive.
If one thought about--thinks
about--a universe of experience,
the three Eisenhower recessions
that were formative for Art,
although I believe the second
of them coincided with my
birth--the 1966-1967 economic
downturn--more conspicuously the
major downturns in '74-'75,
in the wake of the oil supply
shock, and in 1980-'82,
the Volcker disinflation;
these were most of the
experience we had with the
business cycle in a substantial
sloth of economic history.
The economy expanded in one way
or another, inflation got out of
control, people got nervous
about inflation,
the Fed hit the brakes,
interest rates spiked,
the yield curve inverted,
the economy slowed.
To be sure, there were great
controversies about how--what
exactly the mechanism was.
What was the role of credit
rationing in the housing sector
versus higher interest rates?
To what extent did the
transmission mechanism take
place through Tobin's Q.
If one asked,
what was the cause of
downturns, the cause was
monetary.
The accounts of business cycle
historians who tracked events
were couched in those terms.
The enormously influential
monetary history of the United
States emphasized the role of
monetary contractions and of
Federal Reserve policies.
The academic issues of the day,
which focused critically on the
questions of price rigidity,
therefore led to a natural
focus as the canonical
experiment of--suppose you
reduce M,
the money stock,
what happens to the level of
output in the short-run and why
does that happen?
The prevailing view about
business cycles was that they
were determined by monetary
policy and what led to
contractionary monetary policy
was either a mistake by the Fed
or a necessary action by the Fed
as inflation accelerated.
It is interesting to
contemplate that if one looks
before or after what one might
think of as the Okun period and
tries to give a simple account
of what was behind the business
cycles that took place,
one offers a rather different
kind of story.
1907 is linked to a financial
panic;
it couldn't have been caused by
the Feds, since the Fed didn't
exist yet.
In 1929, the actions of the
Federal Reserve in 1928 or 1929
may or may not have been a
crucial causative factor,
but there's a reason they talk
about the stock market crash as
a prelude to The Depression.
The dominant influences were
endogenous to the workings of
the financial system.
If one thinks about the three
most recent instances of
cyclical fluctuation in the
United States,
the 1990,1992 case can be
debated.
There was an oil shock;
there had been some tightening
of monetary policy,
but I think most observers
would assign dominant influence
to the problems in the financial
system associated with the
S&L's and the overextension
of banks in real estate lending.
There's no question that almost
any close watcher,
if asked to say,
what was the 2001 recession
about,
they would say bursting of the
technology bubble.
I'll have more to say about the
2008 recession a little later
and tomorrow,
including some speculations on
the probability that there is
one.
No one would say of the current
fluctuation that it reflected
the Federal Reserve's excessive
or necessary effort to curb
inflation in product price
markets.
Rather, they would attribute it
in one way or another to
something endogenous to the
financial system.
The debates would turn on
whether it was best thought of
in terms of a housing price
bubble;
whether it was best thought of
as a matter having to do with
the excessive extension of
subprime credit;
whether it was a reflection of
a generalized excessive
complacency in credit markets
that led to the extension of
financial institutions.
All of those questions could be
debated, but no serious dispute
about the proposition that it
came out of the workings of the
financial system.
With this history before us,
in thinking about macroeconomic
policy and in thinking about
cyclical fluctuations,
seems to me appropriate that we
at least consider redirecting
some macroeconomic attention
from traditional preoccupations
with the price setting
process--the Phillips Curve--and
disinflation to more traditional
Keynesian preoccupations with
the workings of the financial
system with animal
spirits--with,
if you like,
shocks to the IS Curve that
come out of the workings of the
financial system.
This view, I would suggest,
is certainly confirmed by less
detailed reflection on
international experience.
One thinks about the two most
dramatic OECD macroeconomic
events of the last twenty years.
They are almost always--excuse
me, President Zedillo,
[former Mexican President
Ernesto Zedillo,
who was among the people seated
in the classroom for Summers'
lecture.]
permanent OECD member events,
so I exclude the drama of which
you were a--you were so central,
so central a part.
They were, almost certainly,
the Japanese financial crisis
followed by depression in the
1990s and the dramatic declines
in output associated with the
failure of the banking system,
to the point where it needed to
be nationalized in the Nordic
countries in the early 1990s.
Indeed, it is interesting to
note that in recent years
financial crises have become
pervasive.
One always remembers the
comments one makes about
economic fluctuations that prove
to be prescient and forgets the
ones that prove to have been
completely wrong.
I am no exception.
I will recall that I was fond
of observing in 2005 and 2006
that if one looked at the last
twenty years,
there had been six or
seven--six major financial
crises: the 1987 stock market
crash;
the 1990 savings and loan real
estate crash;
the 1995 Mexican crash--some
would argue that if this is a
U.S.
list, that Mexico doesn't
belong and one could have that
argument--the 1997 Asian
financial crisis;
the events associated with LTCM
and Russia that President
Clinton and Secretary Rubin,
at the time,
labeled the most serious
financial crisis since the
Second World War;
and the 2001 financial crisis
associated with the bursting of
the tech bubble,
problems in the high yield
sector, the subsequent problems
in capital markets--exemplified
by what happened at Enron.
It is interesting to ask the
question, whether there is some
relation between all these
events.
Because what I've suggested so
far is that if one distinguishes
the last generation from the
preceding generation--in the
preceding generation,
financial crises were
relatively rare;
business cycles were caused by
the Federal Reserve
eliminating--Federal Reserve's
concern about inflation.
For the last generation,
business cycles have been
associated with financial crisis
and the Federal Reserve has not
caused downturns through its
concern with inflation.
How are these events linked?
I'm not entirely sure.
Sitting in the Brookings
Papers meetings for all
these years, I've learned how
Bill Nordhaus is hard to
satisfy.
Sometimes people have
t-statistics of three and Bill
pronounces them to be
quote-unquote Darwinian,
reflecting the data mining of
the author.
On other occasions,
they have only a few
observations,
in which case they're deemed to
have committed one-observation
econometrics.
I'm going to commit about
four-observation econometrics
and offer the hypothesis that
the right way to understand this
pattern is that we
achieved--that Art's generation
and then Paul Volcker--achieved
a hugely important thing.
They achieved a measure of
credibility and commitment to
non-inflationary monetary
policies that enabled inflation
expectations to be kept in
check.
That, just as success in curing
infectious disease leads there
to be far more cancer than there
was before infectious disease
was brought in check,
so too the achievement of
disinflation leads to an economy
in which expansions are enabled
to continue until they lead to
the complacency and confidence
associated with financial
crisis.
Perhaps we will have 6%
inflation two years from now and
the Fed will cause--Fed will
find it necessary to engineer a
recession and this theory will
fall completely by the wayside.
Perhaps there is an
alternative, more compelling
explanation for this pattern.
But for now,
I would adduce the hypothesis
that the increased incidence of
financial crisis and the closer
relationship between financial
crisis and economic downturns is
a by-product of our success in
achieving low and credible
inflation and the associated
great moderation.
Whether or not we can accept
that idea as to why financial
crisis seems to have been the
cause of previous recessions
where it was not previously,
the empirical observation
stands that financial crises are
frequent and that not
infrequently,
when there is a financial
crisis, it leads to some
significant disruption in real
economic activity.
It follows that the causes of
financial crisis and the policy
response to financial crisis
need to occupy a larger part of
our consideration of
macroeconomics than they have
traditionally.
I should suggest also that this
is--this conclusion is
reinforced by the observation
that,
whereas disinflation recession
lends itself very much to the
unfortunate conservation
argument I presented at the
beginning that suggested that
you couldn't really alter the
output gap over long periods of
time if you did not want to
accept changes in inflation.
It is easy to understand
financial crisis and the
associated downturns in output
as a reduction in aggregate
supply.
And, therefore,
[it is]
highly plausible to believe
that the better management of
financial crisis or the
prevention of financial crisis
will lead not just to a smoother
path of output,
but a path that,
by avoiding downturns,
has a higher average over long
periods of time.
And, therefore,
[it]
is more successful in achieving
the goal that Art Okun and Jim
Tobin and Yale,
for many, many years,
set for macroeconomic policy of
raising the average level of
output.
Now, discussions of financial
crisis tend to have the
character of accident
investigations.
There are many different
suspects;
great numbers of details are
mustered to tell the story.
There are always particular
words associated with particular
financial crises.
One talks about portfolio
insurance in the context of the
1987 crash.
One talks about Tesobonos in
the context of the Mexican
experience.
One talks about bubble
psychology in the context of the
NASDAQ experience.
One uses the--one speaks about
the viscidities of the
separation between the
originators and the owners of
mortgages in talking about the
current subprime mortgage
crisis.
It all brings to mind Tolstoy's
observation that every happy
family is the same and every
unhappy family is miserable in
its own way.
It is all correct--not all of
it is correct--but in each of
the crises there are important
elements of institutional detail
of particular practice that
explain how the story played out
in the way that it did.
I want to suggest that there is
some common structure that lies
behind the various phenomena
that are associated with
financial crisis.
The understanding of which can
at least help us to think about
the mechanism of crisis and
perhaps the appropriate policy
responses.
For thinking about financial
crises, economics has a classic
metaphor that captures many
elements of the problem.
It's a set of ideas that go
back at least to Bagehot
[British businessman and writer
Walter Bagehot,
1826-1877]
economic history and are known
to current economic theorists as
Diamond-Dybvig phenomena.
[Douglas Diamond and Philip
Dybvig, "Bank Runs,
Deposit Insurance and
Liquidity,"
Journal of Political Economy,
91(3), 1983]The idea is simple,
powerful, and incomplete.
Imagine a bank;
the bank takes deposits;
the deposits can be withdrawn
at any moment or at least can be
withdrawn at high frequency.
It takes the deposits and it
lends the money for projects.
The projects have a higher rate
of return than the deposits do,
but the projects take some
significant time to complete and
there is no market for a
half-finished project.
Think about that financial
institution;
perhaps it also chooses to keep
a portion of its deposits on
hand in cash.
A moment's reflection on that
financial institution will cause
you to recognize that it is
subject to multiple equilibria.
If everyone believes that the
bank will remain healthy,
the bank will in fact remain
healthy.
Depositors all can be paid back;
the project will be completed;
the bank shareholders are
better off;
the depositors are better off;
the entrepreneurs who have been
lent money for their projects
are better off.
It is a Nash Equilibrium and
everyone is better off.
It is not, however,
the only Nash Equilibrium.
A moment's thought will also
cause you to realize that if
everyone else is taking their
money out of the bank,
then you are well advised to
take your money out of the bank
as soon as you can because the
bank is not going to be able to
pay off all of the claims on it.
A solvent bank is subject to
self-fulfilling prophecy.
It can either remain solvent or
it can fail depending upon the
state not just of expectations,
but in a manner much like
Keynes's Beauty
Contest--expectations of others'
expectations.
If I expect that you expect
that TN [Professor T.
N.
Srinivasan, Yale University]
expects that the bank is going
to fail and that he is going to
withdraw money,
then the safer thing for me to
do is to withdraw money.
If one wants a simple theory of
why if you go to any American
town and you look for the most
solidly built building,
with the most impressive
façade,
it will be a building that was
used as a bank,
particularly if it was
constructed before the era of
deposit insurance.
It is precisely this notion of
multiple equilibrium that
explains why banks,
more than other institutions,
are at such pains to project
credibility and to project
permanence.
Notice that this metaphor is
very powerful and is very
suggestive of a case for
activism because it suggests
that there are multiple
possibilities to which the free
market will be subject.
It suggests that if
coordination can be achieved,
there are possibilities that
are unambiguously better for
everyone and possibilities that
are worse for everyone.
It suggests a natural role for
government as a coordinator or
as a guarantor in favor of the
better equilibrium.
Now to be sure,
the more rigorous and skeptical
among you will have noticed that
I slipped an important issue by
in telling this story;
I said quickly that there was
no market for unfinished
projects.
It's hard to understand why,
if it's a certainty that all
unfinished projects are going to
succeed and it's a certainty
that when they do succeed the
bank will have more money--have
enough money--to pay off its
depositors;
why there will not be some
profit-maximizing actor who is
prepared to come in and buy
those unfinished projects and,
in the process,
make the depositors whole.
In the language that is always
used in talking--frequently used
in talking--about financial
crisis,
it's hard to understand how you
can have a liquidity problem
without at least the possibility
of a solvency problem.
And once you have the
possibility of a solvency
problem, it becomes less clear
just how much you're making
everybody better off by lending
the money or by allowing the
projects to be partially
completed.
Nonetheless,
this liquidity--nonetheless,
this Diamond-Dybvig bank run
metaphor has been very powerful
in influencing financial policy
in a wide range of situations.
It was this idea that was the
justification,
albeit without mentioning
Diamond or Dybvig's name,
that Secretary Rubin [Treasury
Secretary Robert Rubin]
and I used in explaining to
President Clinton why it was
important that we support Mexico
in 1995 and in countless other
efforts of what their supporters
call support programs and their
opponents call bailouts in
financial history.
When institutions or countries
or individuals in financial
distress were provided with
support,
the concept of it's a liquidity
problem, so by providing support
we can coordinate around the
positive equilibrium,
was invoked.
This idea of a bank run or a
set of bank runs and the
provision of support provides a
powerful way of thinking about a
destructive,
gap-increasing financial crisis.
It certainly fits a variety of
situations--the situation that
Mexico faced in 1985;
perhaps the situation that Bear
Stearns faced several weeks ago;
certainly the situation that
the Fed was concerned about that
has led it to provide financial
support in the form of back-stop
facilities of many kinds to many
financial institutions.
It does not really address or
seem in an obvious way to apply
to many of the financial crises
that we observe.
Many of the financial crises
that we observe--think of the
1987 crash or think about events
in the housing market or
mortgage market today--involve
freely traded assets;
they don't involve banks;
they don't seem to involve bank
runs.
What I'd like to suggest--and I
can only suggest this in an
imprecise way--is that in an
important sense there is a broad
class of behavior that goes on
in speculative markets that is
in its character very similar to
the character of a bank run.
One way of thinking about that
bank run is to think about the
value that you associate with a
deposit claim on the bank in
question.
There's this troubled--there's
this bank;
in normal times,
I have a one dollar deposit.
The deposit is worth one
dollar--have a one dollar
deposit that's worth one
dollar--that's easy.
Now, imagine that the price of
that deposit falls because there
comes to be a question whether
that bank is going to succeed or
whether that bank is going to
fail or,
for that matter,
that the price of that claim
falls because of doubts about
the solvency of the bank.
Do I, as a depositor,
wish to put more deposits into
the bank because the price has
fallen?
Or do I wish to sell my claim
as rapidly as I can?
Think about it for a minute.
The situations in which the
values of deposits are falling
are the very situations in which
you are most eager to sell those
deposits back to the bank.
To go back to economics'
standby, the most basic idea
that we teach freshmen in
economics is the law of supply
and demand--the stabilizing
nature of markets--markets as a
negative feedback mechanism.
We tell the story in lots of
ways;
there's a surplus of apples;
when there's a surplus of
apples, the price falls,
and then demand increases,
then there isn't a surplus of
apples anymore.
There's a shortage of apples,
the price rises and then there
isn't a shortage of apples
anymore.
Our basic image of the economic
system is as a
self-equilibrating system with a
single equilibrium that is
determined by that law of supply
and demand.
If the demand curve slopes in
the wrong way--if a falling
price leads to less demand or,
equivalently,
to more supply--then none of
our normal intuitions work.
Price falls in response to
excess demand and rises in
response to excess supply,
magnifying the excess.
If there's a single
equilibrium, it can be unstable.
If the demand curve has the
more exotic shape that goes with
some people responding to price
over some range by reducing
demand and others responding by
increasing demand;
and there are other
possibilities.
I draw here a diagram that's
been produced many times,
in many different contexts,
where you engage in the
intellectual exercise of--this
is complicated;
this is wild;
this is really crazy.
Let's think of a reason why the
demand curve could have both
slopes.
Let's suppose that sometimes
there's the normal slope and
sometimes it has the other.
Then, if it fits together in
the right way,
there can be two
equilibria--one good and one
bad.
One could clearly proliferate
examples of this kind.
If there is a mechanism present
more generally in financial
markets that causes the price
of--the demand for financial
assets to increase with price or
to decrease with supply or
to--or causes demand to decrease
as price falls,
then one has the possibility of
instability that has very much
the character of the bank run.
Is this a reasonable hypothesis
to maintain?
This brings us,
and I will not dwell on this at
any length, to a broad set of
issues associated with
behavioral finance.
Like Bob Shiller,
I was very struck when I
encountered the assertion of
Mike Jensen and others in the
late 1970s that the efficient
market hypothesis was the
best-established fact in the
social sciences.
By the way, that didn't
necessarily mean that it was a
well established fact,
but as Jensen used the term
that was its meaning.
I have to say that as I make
that remark about social
sciences, I'm reminded of the
observation somebody once
offered--that if you have to
call it science,
it isn't--cognitive science,
Christian science,
political science,
social science--and so I have,
ever since hearing that,
never used the term economic
science to refer to any
phenomenon.
These issues were crystallized
for me.
I had followed Bob's work on
excess volatility and tried to
contribute some of my own on the
power of statistical tests.
I was struck by the bitterness
of the controversies that
surrounded Bob's work on excess
volatility.
In particular,
where so many in finance seemed
to regard attacks on the
efficient market hypothesis in
rather the way they would regard
attacks on their spouses or
children,
and called for not just a
rational rejoinder,
but some effort at the
destruction of the assailant.
I remember that my sense of the
issue and the merits,
where my sympathies had always
been with Bob,
crystallized in the summer of
1987.
In the summer of 1987,
there was a certain set of
facts that was very clear.
It was very clear in the summer
of 1987 that if you divided
stock prices by any interesting
denominator,
they were at an extraordinarily
high level--earnings,
dividends, sales,
GNP.
If you were at Yale,
the value--the capital--you
added the debt and you divided
by the value of the capital
stock.
It didn't matter,
all denominators;
stock prices were
extraordinarily high.
Then, the question was how to
interpret that observation and
there were two interpretations
on offering.
One was the conventional
interpretation that would have
seemed the only plausible
interpretation to anyone who
read the newspaper,
which was that stocks had been
going great and a lot of people
wanted to buy stock.
Therefore, they all tried to
buy stock and there only was so
much stock and the price went
up.
As a consequence of the price
going up, it was probably true
that the return going forward
was going to be lower than it
had been before the price went
up.
That was one interpretation.
That seemed the obvious and
natural interpretation.
The alternative interpretation
was that, for some reason,
people who used to demand 8%
expected returns to buy stocks
were now demand--had decided for
some reason that they'd really
be just--they used to demand 8%
to buy stocks given the risk,
but all of a sudden for
whatever reason--and the reason
was never spelled out with any
clarity--they now were happy to
accept a 6% rate of return.
Therefore, all the future
dividends and all the future
earnings were discounted at a
lower level.
There was, in a way,
a simple intuition for deciding
what you believed.
Did you believe that returns
were low because stock prices
were high?
Did you believe that stock
prices were high because people
had decided they were perfectly
content with low returns?
Well, it was an easy way to
distinguish those hypotheses.
Bob did it at the time,
which was to ask people,
what returns they were
expecting--what returns they
were settling for.
The answer suggested that,
if anything,
they favored high returns
rather than--they expected
higher returns than they had
previously,
not lower returns than they had
previously.
Why do I dwell on all of this?
Because it is a first example
of what I actually think are a
substantial variety of
mechanisms,
all of which can produce this
kind of positive feedback
behavior in financial markets.
The first and easiest mechanism
for understanding why there will
be positive feedback behavior
or,
equivalently,
a decline in demand as price
falls and an increase in price
in demand as price rises,
is the extrapolative
expectations that come from
recent experiences.
One of the things I learned
painfully, being involved with
managing the dollar as Secretary
of the Treasury,
was there is absolutely no way,
no matter how powerful you are
and no matter how clever you
are,
that the dollar can be lower
without falling.
It cannot happen no matter how
much you want to have a falling
dollar without--a low dollar
without a falling dollar.
In just the same way,
a rising stock price leads to a
higher stock price.
Therefore, if people demand
more after increases in price,
they are demanding more as
price rises.
That's one mechanism through
which there can be positive
feedback.
A second mechanism,
which Bob has put considerable
emphasis on in his writing,
is social contagion.
It's people persuade other
people;
people look at other people.
Basically, the bubble
psychology takes hold as a
social dynamic not necessarily
related to any rational
assessment of the future
behavior of markets.
A third mechanism is one that
can easily be given rational
explanation.
I am the risk manager;
John is a trader.
I don't actually know whether
John knows anything or not;
he says he does,
but he's got a complicated
story and I can't quite tell how
much he knows.
He just lost a lot of money.
Should I have more confidence
in John or should I have less
confidence in John,
knowing that he lost a
lot--that he just lost a lot of
money?
Probably, I should have less
confidence in John.
As an empirical proposition,
his risk manager will have less
confidence in John.
So, positions that do not
succeed have less capital
associated with them than
positions that do succeed,
again creating this kind of
positive feedback.
A fourth mechanism that will
create this kind of positive
feedback derives from leverage.
Anyone who buys on margin or
any financial institution that
has a capital requirement--when
they lose money,
there is a margin call or a
need to generate capital,
which can lead to--that can
lead to the liquidation of
positions;
again, falling price,
more selling.
A fifth example and a fifth
source of positive feedback
comes from what one might think
of as model uncertainty.
There are different ways to
tell the story and I suspect it
could be given much more
rigorous formalization than I'm
going to attempt here.
A prominent macroeconomist,
early in his career,
developed on the basis of some
macroeconomic model that he had
an extremely strong view that
the British pound was going to
depreciate.
With great excitement,
he found an older colleague who
had a broker;
called the broker and explained
that he wished to place an order
in the futures market to sell
the pound short.
The broker said,
okay I've got your order.
What would you like your
stop-loss to be?
The young macroeconomist said,
what's that?
The broker explained that it
was normal that when you placed
a position, in case the position
moved against you,
since you didn't want to lose
too much money and if the
position moved against you,
it might signal that you didn't
understand this--things weren't
playing out according to your
theory of the case--that you
might want to sell.
The macroeconomist said,
hell no.
If it goes up 5%,
I want to buy a lot more.
The young macroeconomist did
not have--went on to have a very
distinguished career as a
macroeconomist,
but a rather less distinguished
career as a speculator.
If I asked you,
in what way would you like to
place a--you have some
conviction.
You've got some idea that the
Yen is going to up--that the Yen
is going to go down--something,
let's suppose it's that the Yen
is going to go up.
I say, would you rather buy
Yen, take your chances that the
Yen might go up or the Yen might
go down, or would you rather buy
an option on the Yen?
If you buy an option on the
Yen, then there's no way,
no matter what happens,
that you can lose more than the
amount that you paid for the
Yen.
You can get very substantial
leverage on the option if you
buy an out-of-the-money option;
you can pay only a very little
bit of money.
If the Yen goes up,
you will multiply your initial
stake by a very substantial
amount.
Most people presented with that
choice, if they believe the
option is priced fairly,
choose to buy the option.
But if you think about what
that means, that is a decision
to pursue a positive feedback
trading strategy.
That is a decision that the
more the position moves in your
favor, the more your option is
in-the-money,
and the larger is your exposure
to the underlying stock or the
underlying currency.
Anyone who chooses to use
options as a trading vehicle is
choosing an approach in which
they are going to increase the
magnitude of their position as
the price rises or decrease the
the price falls--again,
exactly the opposite of the
natural, stabilizing response.
A final source of this kind of
positive feedback is the
prospect that increases in
movement for any of these
reasons are jumped on by those
who simply anticipate the
positive feedback behavior of
others.
Therefore, trends follow in an
effort to front run others who
are generating these trends.
I would suggest to you that
consideration of these
mechanisms, along with
consideration of the experience
in markets--a basic pattern that
we tend to observe in
markets--positive serial
correlation in the short run,
mean reversion in the long
run--suggests the pervasiveness
of this kind of positive
feedback behavior and,
therefore, suggests the
likelihood that financial
markets will be subject to very
substantial instability and
multiple equilibrium.
Just as the positive feedback
associated with the bank run
makes a case for--or least opens
up a case--for activist policy,
so also, in the case of
financial markets,
the possibility of downdrafts
caused by falling prices that
lead to selling--that lead to
more selling--lead to falling
prices--or updrafts caused by
the opposite mechanisms,
make a potentially strong case
for government action to contain
financial crisis.
So far, I've tried to make the
case that I want to make for
today--that the macroeconomics
of the next generation will be
much more about finance and
financial crisis than the
macroeconomics of the
generations that shaped our
textbooks;
that the social gains from
preventing and containing
financial crises are likely to
be significant.
And offer the prospect of
achieving the deep-seated goal
of every Keynesian
macroeconomist:
reducing the average output gap
over a long period of time and
thereby producing more total
output.
That a realistic theory of
financial crisis has to be based
on something other than the idea
that the market is efficient.
And that the notion that bank
run-like behavior can be
generated out of the behavior of
speculative participants in
financial markets who respond
perversely,
from an economist's point of
view, to price signals,
is a highly plausible one.
Tomorrow, I hope to illustrate
that these broad ideas have
connection with the current
financial crisis that we face
and to suggest--to
evaluate--some of the policy
measures that have been
undertaken and to suggest some
policy actions for the future.
Thank you very much.
Bob, I don't know what the
format here is,
but I'd be happy to answer a
few questions.
Yes, sir?
Student: If the
government seeks to stabilize
this plan of avoiding these
perverse positive feedback
consequences,
doesn't that very government
action itself make for this very
possibility?
Does the government continue
doing that and,
therefore, it gets to a point
where it says no,
it will have created its own
positive feedback mechanism
reverse itself?
Professor Larry Summers:
I had a conclusion addressed to
the word moral hazard that I
decided to defer to the first
part of what I was going to say
tomorrow.
But, since you ask essentially
the question,
I'll address it right now.
I chose, in summarizing the
main points, to use the
phrase--this possibility of
positive feedback--open space
for constructive government
action precisely so as to not
judge with absolutism that in
every case there would be
desirable things for governments
to do,
precisely because of the
expectational effects that you
describe.
It seems to me that before
embracing moral hazard
fundamentalism and the idea that
if the government gets involved,
then there will be expectations
of the government doing things,
and then if their expectations
that the government's doing
things,
people will respond to those
expectations and then it'll
surely be bad.
Before embracing that idea,
one needs to pause over three
points.
First, moral hazard is not a
reason why there should not be
insurance or a reason why
problems should not be addressed
by collective action.
The standard wise crack on the
subject is: the fact that I
smoke in bed is not usually
considered a good reason for the
fire department not to come to
my house to put out the fire,
especially if my house borders
very closely on many other
people's houses.
The first point is,
yes there may be adverse
effects that come from the
expectations and there may be
beneficial effects that come
from the direct action;
those have to be traded off.
Second, there is a certain
sloppiness in supposing that all
induced behavioral changes are
to be thought of as undesirable.
Consider a standard bit of
public policy--the placing of
guard rails beside highways.
The government chooses,
as part of the provision of a
public good, to place guard
rails beside highways and to
place good guard rails beside
highways.
It is a documented,
empirical fact that as a
consequence of the presence of
those guard rails,
people drive faster than they
otherwise would.
How should one think about,
as an economist,
the fact that they drive
faster?
As in doing a welfare
evaluation of guard rails,
I think a moment's thought
should convince you that since
they had the option of driving
at the same speed that they did
before,
in the presence of the guard
rails they adjusted their
behavior.
The welfare gain from building
the guard rails is greater than
it would have been if people--is
magnified by the behavioral
response that takes place.
If people decide,
for example,
that because we have deposit
insurance they are not going to
check on the expressions of the
bank tellers at their bank
everyday,
that I would argue is an
induced behavioral response from
a public intervention,
but it is one that magnifies
the gain from deposit insurance
rather than reducing the gain
from deposit insurance.
The third point to be
considered, and it's getting a
bit ahead of our story tomorrow,
is that there is no--is that
one has to very carefully
consider the cost to the
government of contemplated
actions.
People talk about bailouts in a
rather indiscriminate way,
but it is a very different
thing for me to loan my friend,
John, $1,000 than for me to
give my friend,
John, $1,000.
If I loan my friend,
John, $1,000 at a premium
interest rate that exceeds the
cost at which I borrow,
it may even be profitable for
me to lend money to my friend,
John.
If I am making a profit,
the question of in what sense I
am subsidizing him becomes a
rather--becomes a rather subtle
one.
So, take as a concrete example
that poses the issue:
the loan that the United States
made to Mexico in 1995.
The loan that the United States
made to Mexico came at a premium
of, let's say,
on average about 200 basis
points over the Treasury's
borrowing costs.
At the time the United States
made it, Mexico would have
probably been unable to borrow
at any interest rate below 1,000
basis points and perhaps would
have been unable--more
realistically,
probably would have been unable
to borrow at all.
So, how does one think about
that 200 basis-point loan?
One way to think about it is,
we made a profit;
200 is more than 0.
Another way to think about is,
well wait, the market price of
a loan to Mexico was 1,000 basis
points;
we made the loan at 200 basis
points, therefore the loan is
under water in the first
instant.
Another way to think about it
is, well the market price is 200
basis--the market price is 1,000
basis points,
but that's assuming that it's
Citibank trying to collect from
Mexico.
Probably the United States is
going to be much better at
collecting from Mexico for a
variety of reasons than
Citigroup,
just as the Fed is going to be
much better at collecting from
Merrill Lynch than most others.
There's considerable subtlety
involved in judging whether
lending activity at premium
interest rates does or does not
constitute a subsidy.
Almost always,
it will be profitable if paid
back relative to the lender's
borrowing costs.
Almost always,
it will be at an interest rate
that is lower than the borrower
could borrow at on the markets.
And almost always,
in the case of public or
quasi-public activity,
there will be a reasonable
argument that the lender is
better at collecting than the
private sector would have been.
So, the question of evaluating
subsidy is difficult.
The position that I always took
as Secretary of the Treasury,
with respect to the IMF,
was, look we've got a long
experience and over time our
loans have been paid back and
we've made money;
so, you can't really think of
this as bailout and subsidy.
I think it was a pretty strong
argument.
I would want to resist in the
strongest terms the idea that
because government involvement
will affect private sector
behavior,
there is to be some presumption
that it is to be avoided.
Yes?
Student: Why didn't
people see these defaults
coming?
Professor Larry Summers:
The world is a very uncertain
place and default risks are
very, very difficult to judge.
It's far from clear that,
as a general matter,
investors understate default
risks.
Indeed, I think most people who
look closely at pricing patterns
in bond markets would tell you
that,
if anything,
investors systematically
overstate default risks.
So, on a very consistent basis,
if you buy riskier bonds and
sell safer bonds,
that on average proves to be a
profitable strategy and even
proves to be a profitable
strategy adjusting for the
degree of risk that you're
taking.
The premise of policy has
tended to be a great deal of
emphasis on transparency in the
hope that with more transparency
and better information,
investors will make more
rational decisions and will make
more rational decisions ex
ante.
There are also sets of issues
that are involved here--and I'll
say something about this
tomorrow--having to do with the
fact that the optimal number of
auto accidents is not zero.
The optimal number of plane
crashes is not zero.
There is a trade off to be made
between accepting a certain
possibility of accidents and a
variety of advantages that come
from the conservation of capital
and the making available of
finance in a variety of ways.
Thank you very much.